and now an update on a segment we
brought you last night I expressed
concern that New Orleans Saints
quarterback Drew Brees was being
subjected to withering criticism for
answering a question about what NFL
protests might look like next season now
he said the flag shouldn't be
disrespected and that he thinks of his
veteran grandfather's and the civil
rights pioneers when he hears our
national anthem
now we noted that Brees also cited his
deep Christian faith which of course
teaches that everyone should be treated
equally and with respect and we noted
his generous contributions to charity
now my defense of Brees led to an online
course of people comparing those
comments to previous comments I had made
to LeBron James now at the time James
had said that Trump quote really doesn't
give an F close quote
about the people well without dwelling
on the nuance between the two instances
let me be very clear about what I
believe we are all children of God
regardless of our racial or political
differences and therefore must be
treated equally every American every
American it has a god-given right to
speak his or her own mind on any issue
and I think in order to heal and shed
light on gross and justices our country
needs more dialogue not less and we need
more respect not retribution emotions
are hot right now and unfortunately in
times like these we often find ourselves
I know it's easy to do just talk past
each other but right now Americans I
think most of them are looking for
reconciliation and that means
politicians police and even cultural
figures all working together all of us
now we're all human beings
and we're on this earth for a very short
period of time when you think about it
and this is a moment when we should be
listening and learning